what's in here what does it do and can I
make it from scratch it's the stuff
inside your Sun ingredients toothpaste
as we know it is relatively new only 150
years old toothpaste as we don't know it
with things like rock salt
pumice crushed eggshells crushed bone
and even crushed oyster shells this kind
of toothpaste is a lot older 5000 years
old some people say others say only 2500
now the weird thing is old toothpaste
and modern toothpaste not all that
different we have and titanium dioxide
now that is kind of a long list but we
can split it up into different
categories first and foremost are the
abrasives now abrasives are things like
sandpaper or steel wool or pumice
abrasives literally scrape food and
other gunk like plaque off your teeth
now I'm not gonna lie when I discovered
there were abrasives in a toothpaste I
was surprised I mean if you live a good
long life you will spend 2,000 hours
more or less brushing your teeth
imagine sandpapering a bone for 2,000
hours you would end up with nothing but
powder but your teeth are actually
harder than bone and iron and steel now
different manufacturers use different
abrasives in their toothpaste but they
all make up a good chunk of the final
product anywhere between thirty to sixty
percent now the abrasive in this
toothpaste is hydrated silica which
believe it or not is the very same thing
you find in these packets in your
luggage and vitamin bottles except with
water added now if you ever take
toothpaste and rub it between two
fingers what you'll find is that it's
not that rough and that's for a really
simple reason it's because your gums are
long more fragile than your teeth so you
don't overdo it on the roughness the
second category is called humectants a
humectant is something that helps retain
water and that is what gives toothpaste
it's and this is a direct quote from
this manufacturers customer service rep
smooth and creamy texture anyway the
humectants in here are glycerin sorbitol
and propylene
glycol and two of those molecules
actually have an additional function
they are sweet and they're not as sweet
as sugar though so most manufacturers
add some sort of artificial sweetener on
top could be something like saccharine
in here or xylitol in here now none of
those artificial sweeteners break down
to form acids like sugar does so that's
why they don't cause cavities and you
can use them in toothpaste and then of
course there are flavors which are there
to make the toothpaste taste not awful
and your mouth filled clean now in our
case and in almost every case you will
find flavorings super precisely
described as flavour so that
manufacturers can't steal each other's
corporate secrets
okay so we got abrasives humectants
sweeteners and flavorings
next up foaming agents just like you
find in soap or shampoo except here
there's just one sodium lauryl sulfate
SLS as it's called in the business foams
up real nice when you brush real nice
some people say that all this foam traps
some of the gunk that the abrasives
scrape off your teeth that's chemically
not unreasonable but I think the reason
that most modern toothpastes have all
those foaming agents is because you
really feel good making foam like you're
doing something you are cleaning your
teeth now you can't actually buy non
foaming toothpaste if you want okay so
the next category is thickeners and
binders which keep your toothpaste from
becoming a runny watery disgusting mess
or separating out like natural peanut
butter so the ones that we have in this
toothpaste are cellulose gum and
carrageenan which come from trees and
red seaweed respectively okay so we are
finally at the last three ingredients
these don't really fit in the category
all right so first there's sodium
fluoride which is in almost every
toothpaste manufacturer today and
prevents cavities
next up is sodium hydroxide which bumps
the pH up you don't really want to be
brushing your teeth with acid
finally there's titanium dioxide which
makes your toothpaste white without it
it'd be like a dull gray and no one
wants that so now that we figured out
what's in toothpaste and how it works
I'm gonna try and make my own from
scratch using only natural ingredients
first I need an abrasive my brace if has
to not dissolve in water
because if it dissolves in water then
it's no longer a solid and it can't rub
stuff off my teeth and I'm going to use
something that you can find in rocks all
over nature calcium carbonate otherwise
known as chalk and because I don't want
my toothpaste to taste horrible I'm
going to use sila tall as a sweetener
and peppermint oil as a flavoring I've
also got glycerin this is my humectant
it's going to keep everything nice and
moist now all three of these they come
from plants I'm not going to bother with
sodium fluoride because I'm not going to
use this toothpaste for the rest of my
life and I'm also not going to bother
with sodium lauryl sulfate the foaming
agent because I'm really care if this
foams up so let's just do this see what
happens
[Music]
okay
here we go and I guess I just that's
about right right okay here we got you
right here ah how bad it tastes um um
tastes like vaguely rocky toothpaste is
honestly what it tastes like there's
there's a little bit of peppermint
there's some sweetness and then it
tastes like earth not like dirt but like
like minerals um not bad I would give
this a solid 7 out of 10 I mean I'll
probably never use it again but 7 out of
10 nonetheless if you guys have ideas on
how to improve the recipe or if you have
an idea for an episode let me know in
the comments or hit me up on Twitter
until then
you